hallo Bushido ich würde dich gerne
fragen welches Lied du deiner Meinung
nach am besten findest sei sei es wegen
dem Text oder weil du damit positive
Gedanken verbindest oder das rüber
gebracht hast was du rüberbringen
wolltest besonders gut oder welches Lied
du nicht so gut findest sei der Sekte
Track in der zweiten Ansage oder oder
irgendein Lied wo bei dir du dir denkst
das hätte jetzt nicht sein müssen
ob es überhaupt so ein Lied gibt und
welches das ist würde mich gerne
interessieren ich würde lieber darüber
reden welchen Song ich gut finde also es
gibt
viele Songs die ich wahrscheinlich nicht
so gut finde
aber persönlich finde ich z.B den Song
mit Glashaus auf meinem neuen Album sehr
schön es gibt so den ein oder anderen
Song auf meinem Album den ich auch sehr
gut finde
weil er auch wirklich positiv auch auf
die Menschen wirkt und ich nicht immer
nur irgendwie alles kaputt mache da sind
auf dem neuen albumzeiten ändern ich auf
jeden Fall sehr viele Songs drauf und
deswegen würde ich sagen hör dir das
neue Album an und dann weißt Du schon
welchen Song ich meine